This is a quick demonstration of recent enhancements
in our Genome Data Viewer, including several
track graph settings and the ability to apply
settings to all tracks in a composite Track
Hub.
Even though today's examples use the Genome
Data Viewer, these enhancements also apply
to other NCBI resources that incorporate the
Sequence Viewer, such as SNP and Gene.
Starting on the GDV home page, use the Browse
genome button to go into the current human
assembly, GRCh38.
Then in the Tracks menu, use Configure Track
Hubs, and connect to the Blueprint epigenomics
hub,
which you see is a composite track.
I've already selected a few of the bigWig
tracks, but notice that you can adjust some
track settings right here in this hub configuration
menu,
including an option to apply these settings
to the entire group.
I'll hit Configure,
and these tracks load in the Viewer.
I used the search widget to go to the region
of the rcc1 gene, mostly just to zoom in a
bit.
And let's say you want a cleaner view of the
peaks in this lower track, which now has a
maximum value of 4.3 in the default linear
scale.
Click on the track name, or you can also just
hover on the track name then click on the
gear icon in the tooltip menu that appears.
I'll change to a line graph, and set the value
range, from 1 to 4 for this linear scale.
Notice that this menu includes the option
to apply these settings to the entire Blueprint
group.
We even indicate where data have been clipped
in the newly set range - note the red region.
To show a few more new features, I'll go back
to the Configure Track Hubs menu to connect
to a different hub and select two tracks that
display as a merged track.
Here is that merged track, which combines
data for both splice donor and splice acceptor
predictions, in green and red, respectively.
But you can now separate them into individual
tracks by choosing the Stacked view.
You can also change the color scheme, in what
we call a subtrack.
If I click on the green side, the menu opens
with that track selected.
But you can can change the color and other
subtrack settings for both tracks in this
menu.
You can also hide one of the tracks.
To recover that subtrack, go back in to the
menu, select the hidden subtrack, and uncheck
Hide subtrack.
That's it for this demonstration.
You can review these new features in a post
to our blog, NCBI Insights,
ncbiinsights.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
And as always, we'd love to have your feedback
and questions.
Feedback is right here, and for questions,
please use our Support Center.